[Music]
foreign
and we've been dating for four months
now I'm Jamie I'm Baron this is Rose
we've been here for eight months now I'm
Mason and this is Bree we've been 83
years now I'm Zach this is khaleesia
we've been married for a year
I'm Bailey this is Carla we've been
dating for nine months now I'm Elliot
this is Lucia and we've been dating for
a year and a half
we're John and Jess we've been dating
for almost five years next month
I only have one thing that will be
pretty Surefire way to suss out them all
okay if everyone's cool with it all
right deep breath in
deep breath out
okay both hands up
now if your mole put the hand down
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
this one was the first time we went out
together and we took this really cool
picture of her this is him at the beach
the dogs is a lock screen they could
have broken up and still share a dog
very true and
over here
I love you I love you
that's a married kiss me
where do you guys see each other
well I just wanted to point out like you
guys said like I love you like super
super quiet that's okay
pretty good
[Music]
we're all saying I love you and they
were just like I love you
they were the only ones at the start to
like point us out and then when we did
that little thing what was it like the
breathing technique and they put their
hand down that was like the first thing
the raise your hands thing I just
immediately latched onto that
[Applause]
okay
I will give you guys each 60 seconds to
try to save yourself I don't want to
like tug on like heartstrings or
anything like that but like he's been my
rock through like some of the toughest
times of my life right now sorry I've
been like in and out of the hospital and
he's been there by my side he's my you
you always tell him it's not going
anywhere
we're sticking through it forever well
you guys would feel suspicious because
we seem distant but this is like this is
my person
um if we do get voted out you guys want
to like you know we're not the most so
really I have to say so and then people
have concerns about the I love you so we
can do that oh
thank you
being the first couple out isn't exactly
fun yeah it has to be lowering my hands
I realized I sealed Our Fate so I know
we all kind of showed that we were
comfortable saying I love you to each
other so can we say like when we knew we
fell in love with each other we've been
hooking up for a while
I thought she just was like I was trying
to be single but but this one changed my
mind
oh I saw her kind of like pet hair on
the back you know I just thought that I
thought that was like a really friendly
thing to do we were also like kind of
just getting the vibe that they were
more so like Friends with Benefits sort
of thing so we've been dating since high
school we were like around 15 16 when we
started dating
um he said I love you first I can't
remember the exact moment but I feel
like we've just grown together and we've
been through so many lucky events yeah
uh we met in college we were kind of
like friends of friends at first there
was one time she made like a picnic and
she took me to like this big field I
planned that date because I was like he
hasn't told me he loves me but I'm going
to tell him I love him so I literally
played because I'm like so I planned
this whole date and then he says it
first and I was like you stole my moment
the first time we said I love you was
when we were at your cousin's house yeah
she just looked at me and she was just
looking at both my eyes just Frozen here
but then yeah I ended up saying it and I
meant it I had to take care of this girl
and she was like going to Knott's Berry
Farm to meet her online friends and I
had to take her but he was insistent
that he came with me I was like no
you're gonna hate it but he was like
please let me just at least keep you
company all the rides that we try to go
on were completely shut down we were
sweating it was the worst I would do it
all over crazy yeah the focus of their
story wasn't really about like being in
love like it really seemed like their
day at amusement park like they kind of
got lost in the T engine I think I've
been falling deeper and deeper in love
in different moments in time I don't
think it's just one time I think it's
like a degree
sorry I got nervous at the time
I don't know a reality TV show couple
that stuck together too long so it made
sense
[Music]
for you
goodbye
because like we're gay maybe our
friendship overtakes our Dynamic with
each other like maybe that's where a lot
of our chemistry is because I feel like
a lot of like two Girl x's like end up
staying friends sometimes exactly
one two
three
[Music]
can I ask like a really deep question
what was your guys's last argument and
what was it about
but I guess it will start it was
centered around like distance and
availability my brother plays football
so I don't see him too much uh so this
particular time I had took the weekend
to spend time with him and then it was
on Labor Day Labor Day weekend and our
anniversary
we made it work the biggest arguments
that we get into are centered around the
fact that she runs her own business it's
a writer photography business so I try
to help out with that and I'm not the
best at it yet and I'm still learning so
she gets frustrated with me yeah and I
get frustrated with her I'm a very clean
organized person I I think I get a
little like controlling on Thursday I
had like a bad meeting at work I worked
like seven hour weeks and I just came
home and I was just like exhausted and
she's like why are the dishes still in
the dishwasher I'm like I'm sorry and
then like we kind of got in like a
little fight you see us like kind of
like bickering a lot but that's just
like her personalities oh that's our
love language yeah
um I think our biggest fight was similar
to y'alls it was actually also our
anniversary so at this time last year we
had a really big fight it lasted for
like three weeks yeah where he had said
yes to a commitment on our anniversary
you know I have reservations for stuff
and whatnot and you didn't even talk to
me about that yeah so I she's the first
relationship I've ever had so like I
didn't have that stuff but let's kick it
with you guys
there was like a little cut on her foot
and she just kind of let it sit and for
a solid month it's just kind of like
getting worse and I'm like have you
cleaned this yet and she's like no I was
like oh my God why I thought that I did
their argument about a cut that she got
on her foot was weird
the only one talking and leading the
discussion the second the timing started
was Mason
argument question
was amazing I just want to make sure you
have all ten toes
[Applause]
one two three
all right
okay
[Music]
box turns red you guys lose in multiple
this and it says they're still among you
guys you ready
three
two one
[Music]
[Applause]
is it you guys
okay
[Music]
one two three
[Applause]
we got duped yeah that was definitely
the last person I thought they did good
I feel fooled top 5 anime betrayals like
Jews
I don't think I even want to eat lunch
with them right now I'm just kind of
sure like we broke up in March so it's
been six months we both have like
different goals for like what we wanted
to do and it just didn't quite work out
I I feel very grateful like it was like
the best a breakup could be where like
we still like respect each other and
like poke the best for each other but
it's just it just was it
yeah so weird out of the blue driving
home from work he's like do you want to
do this Jubilee video with me I'm like
all right I'm down like why not and now
here we are and we won yeah
well you probably get Ramen after this
yeah we could get food
[Music]